symmetry and common usage is a kind of
vague term like most terms and common
usage we use it flexibly the idea of
symmetry that is turned out to be
extremely fruitful in mathematics and
physics and in the fundamental
description of nature is a precise
distillation of some aspects of the
common usage so it's not unnatural to
call it symmetry but it's something very
precise that that that we can describe
when I when I say what it is it'll sound
kind of mystical but it's actually I'll
spell it out and you'll see what I mean
so symmetry in the sense that's turned
out to be fruitful in mathematics and
physics and fundamental investigations
is change without change now you might
be puzzled what does that have to do
with symmetry well consider a circle a
circle is a very symmetric object you
can rotate it around its center by any
angle and although every point on the
circle may move the circle as a whole
doesn't change and that's what makes it
symmetric in the intuitive sense you can
change it you can make changes on it
which might have changed it but but
although they transform each part of it
don't transform the thing as a whole so
that's what makes a circle a symmetric
object a an equilateral triangle for
instance you can't rotate through any
angle and get the same thing it'll it'll
change if you rotate it one third of the
way around though by 120 degrees
it goes over into itself a rap if your
mote rotate around its center by 120
degrees it's the same equilateral
triangle whereas if you take some
lopsided triangle it'll never go back to
itself until you come all the way back
to a trivial transformation that doesn't
train that doesn't change anything
so change so a triangle has less
symmetry than a circle according to
this concept but more but some symmetry
and so you start to see how this concept
have changed without change matches the
intuitive notion of symmetry the great
advantage of that definition is that you
can apply it in very broad context not
only to describing the symmetry of
objects but to describing the symmetry
of physical laws or the symmetry of
equations so for instance the theory of
relativity is a statement of symmetry
that if you change the way the world
looks by moving past it at a constant
velocity you change the appearance of
everything that's happening but the
underlying laws are still valid that's
the assumption of the theory of
relativity that drives it and makes it
powerful the idea that the laws of
physics don't change as a function of
time is also a symmetry because it means
you can change when you start your
clocks and although the time stamps
you'll give to each event look different
the underlying equations will be the
same that's the way of staying that the
laws of physics don't change and
similarly the way that the the fact that
different the same physical laws apply
at different places as a symmetry
because you can change your position
without changing the way the laws work
so symmetry is a very powerful
constraint on our description of the
world that nature seems to respect in
many ways now the kind of symmetry that
leads to quantum chromodynamics
or general relativity or quantum
electrodynamics is mathematically
considerably more complex but it's the
same idea so there are transformations
of the equations that change the
different terms in them so they might
change an electric field into a magnetic
field or a magnetic field into a
combination of electric and magnetic
that changed the way the equations look
but don't change their consequences so
the equations look quite different some
parts have moved over to the left and
some parts have moved over to the right
and some things have been multiplied in
funny ways but their consequences that
content is exactly the same that's the
kind of equations that are like the
circles among equations are ones that
have this symmetry property and those
are the kinds of equations that turn out
to be the ones that are appear most
prominently in our fundamental
description of nature it's an
extraordinary thing but that's what
that's not only true but that's how we
got to the equations in the first place